going to do the last talk of this
morning by you watch parish for
Microsoft at Red Room at Redmond the
title is concentration of [ __ ]
functionals of determinants own and
other strong rey de measures good
morning almost afternoon and the real
pleasure to be here so this talk so
abbreviated concentration with the
Lipschitz functions or ellipses
functions with negative defendants
huh so this is joint work with Robin
pimento and
so in the data earlier today mentioned
the issue of getting concentration for
functions of negatively dependent
processes and that's hotel focus on our
initial motivation came from from a
question of elgin and myself that we
heard from him which is a let's so let's
go consider
well
be more precise and he was more precise
but for now I'll just write a negatively
dependent process of so this is or
negatively dependent variables x 1 x 2
up to X M so these are 0 1 valued F from
01 to the m2 r is one Lipschitz function
so so of course that just means that if
we have two vectors in c x and y in two
binary vectors and there then the the
distance between f of X and F of Y will
be bounded by the Hamming distance of of
x and y and
and the question is is f of this vector
x1 to xn concentrated and the concrete
example which will also use as a main
example in the discussion is take G
graph and with M edges
he is the uniform spanning three ng
later will also consider waited spanning
trees but now just think of a uniform
spanning tree so all spanning tree is
taken equally likely and then X I just
measures is is the indicator that we
took the ice edge inside p so it's
classical going back to then back to the
19th century even to cook off that there
is some a negative defendants here to
kick off and rayleigh for pairwise
negative dependence there's a stronger
negative dependence in Burton pimentel
93 who showed that this is a determinant
I'll process of mentioned this exactly
the more precisely and and there is a
also a precise negative dependence or
negative association result in this
paper of federally Hal from in 92 show
negative association for this and other
balance metroids so so in this is the
example and then we can take a various
Lipschitz functions F so good examples
to think of and so f of X could be the
number of leaves right so if I CX that
tells me what is the tree and I can ask
for the number of leaves off of the
treaty or I could take f of X to be for
instance half the number of a vertices
of T of all degree in various this is
the the motivation was connected to some
of the recent say works on the Traveling
Salesman problem that employ picking a
spanning tree some waited spanning tree
as a first step and then
completing it with a matching so you
care about the number of vertices of all
degree so so these are ellipses
functions that occur in these
applications so there are relevant works
of a sub area vez Quran madri a sink and
a knee and so which which employ a this
as a step in algorithms for traveling
salesman so this is this is an example
concentration of these variables and the
answer is positive for this example
though we still not know concentration
for Lipschitz functions of any
negatively associated process but i'll
discuss in this negative dependence
property soon now so I'll you know give
more background examples but let me
first just a state one theorem and to
get to that I need our key negative
dependence property which is in this
paper with Samantha and that's the
stochastic a stochastic covering
property
so so first okay so first want to recall
so a strengthening of stochastic
domination so a we say that measure new
one stochastically dominates new too so
there are various equivalent definitions
this is stochastic domain so so
stochastic domination is equivalent to
there is a coupling of the two measures
which is supported on the set of vectors
X Y with X greater equal Y so this is
one of the equivalent versions due to
stresses theorem of stochastic
domination I can couple them so that the
variable with distribution new one
dominates the variable new to now I'm I
want to define the new one so new one
covers New to buy one so want to define
this notion this this will be defined if
there is a coupling on
the pairs X Y where X is greater than y
by one and the last thing I need to
define X greater than Y by one means
this means that x is greater than Y but
their Hamming distance is just one so
they're just different a single bit okay
and finally new has the SCP so a measure
has a stochastic covering property what
it means is if if X is dominates y x 1
if X dominates one why buy one then then
if I take the measure and condition say
X on some set X to be to be equal to X
so right this way new conditioned on the
variables on some set s to be equal to X
this should be dominated by one by new
conditioned on X sub s equals why there
is so there is stochastic so as a
covering property means there is some
compensation so let me make this more
concrete in the case of the spanning
tree so so let's take a graph so the
spanning tree is a prime example of the
stochastic covering property and so
suppose we want to look at the uniform
spanning tree of this of this graph M so
all we condition on this edge being in
the spanning tree turn to look at so I
want to look at this is the ust of this
graph but but with the blue edge so okay
so the blue edge so the blue edge has to
be in the USD and then what times
claiming is that this is if I ignore the
blue it this is going to be dominated by
one by the UST of the graph with the
blue edge removed so here I'm saying I'm
insisting on this edge not being in the
tree so so x and y I should've
emphasized so x and y you C X s equals x
so this means x and y here are in zero
one to the s thank you okay so i have
have vectors x and y which are just
restricted just defined on s okay and x
is bigger than Y so x is bigger than Y
by one on s now I look at the complement
of s I look at this at the other
variables and there I want the relation
to reverse so on the other variables I
can complete the vector so that a so
that on the other variables I'll have
the measure bigger by one in why when I
conditioned on why then why conditioned
on X let me explain this in the context
of the spanning tree to make it more
concrete put a condition and it's
finding tree to contain this edge then
on the remaining graph I'm going to
so it has to contain this edge on the
remaining graph I'm not going to get
spanning tree I'll get in you know I'll
get a subset in general it's say in
general it's a forest because these two
these two have to be in different
components so so the spanning tree in
the original graph the spanning tree had
you know here has three edges and once I
condition on this edge being in I have
two edges left to select on this side I
conditioned this edge not to be in so I
still have three edges to select and the
statement is that I can do that in such
a way i can pick the you know this
little forest here so the two missing
edges here and the three edges here in
such a way that these three edges on the
right the spanish and i will always
contain the two edges on the left i can
always do that so that's a property of
the uniform spanning tree that's in fact
in there so feather and michelle proves
that uniform spanning trees and other
balance metroids have a the negative
association property and but if you look
in they didn't define the stochastic
covering property but in fact the first
half of their proof entails proving the
stochastic covering property and that
was the tool and then in the second half
of the proof they deduce the negative
association property so I'm not so
yes in stochastic pop covering together
with homogeneity so a so at least in the
first part of the talk most of the
talking limit myself to a homogeneous
measures which means the total number of
ones is fixed to be some number K as we
have in this family hey but but in
general we care about negatively
dependent measures without this
condition but the condition simplifies
things a lot and so yes so thank you
this is for any set s so for any a set s
which is a subset of of 12 m okay so
this is the property of the uniform
spanning tree which is the stochastic
common property and that's now there are
many other measures that have the
stochastic foreign property and I'll
tell you about this definition more
precisely later but maybe I'll put
another another class here so we have a
have here a balanced Metroid's
so balanced Metroid's you just besides
the maitre so you look at the inn set of
collection of basis of a of a mate road
and besides so that's automatically
homogeneous and you just insist on
pairwise negative correlations and then
so balanced metro is automatically so
okay nothing really so the theorem of
federer mihalik balance mate roads have
negative association property aim as I
said it see the proof contains the fact
that they have a stochastic covering
property i I didn't I am not so I'm not
explicitly using it but let's still
define it so negative association for
the variables means that if Fame s1 s2
are disjoint a subset of the array of
the variables of the index set then x is
restricted to s1 if I have some function
f of this and the G restricted to s2
these are negatively correlated so the
expectation of this product is less than
the product of the expectation
for any F and G that are increasing ok
so the positive association is the
inequality going the other way and
there's no restriction that the
dependence on the disjoint sets of
variables now of course by Cauchy
Schwarz every you know any variable is
positively dependent on itself so in
order to make a this work for negative
one insists that the sets of variables
are disjoint okay so yes so once right
so so so you conditioned XS xsi possess
now you look at the distribution of the
other variables yes I didn't write that
explicitly but yes so you look at the
situation of the other variables and the
other variables should kind of
compensate you have an extra a bit in
the in X then on the other variables you
should be missing a bit so you have but
you can't say which bit right so you
have a coupling on the remaining
variables that will be depressed by one
if you condition on the variables and s2
have an extra one and the fact that the
SCP implies negative association is
immediate no that's this so so in the
homogeneous okay so in the homogeneous
case that's a second part of the feather
me healthier but for us we don't need
this implication so because will work
directly with the SCP so for us the
important thing is not negative
association rather this it's a
stochastic covering property itself but
ok so aim
let me state already the film under the
SCP so right Sophie if the if the log
the distribution of X has the ICP okay
so they ran the variables meaning their
distribution have the ICP and it's and
I'm going to assume that the process is
homogeneous so the Sun XII from 1 to M
equals sum K so this is what happens to
all for us in a uniform spanning tree
when K is you know the number of
vertices minus 1 m and then I said f is
the f is a 1 Lipschitz function on 0 1 3
m this is the limit theorem of this
paper with Samantha or the main theorem
in the homogeneous case then the
probability the type of X differs from
its mean a more than a so i'll just
write the one-sided inequality and of
course reverse is bounded by e to the
minus a squared over 8k
now
ok so in particular this implies the
concentration for the expanding tree
case then take Kay Kay to be n minus 1
yes too strong really know it does so s
SCP extends the strong Railly this is
Morden so so I said in the beginning I'm
stating the homogeneous case and i'll
come back to the non-homogeneous but ok
let me aim since questions right let me
state this theorem for this for strong
whaley so if fame so if x is strong
rayleigh now what does that what does
that mean well i'll just write the
definition it won't tell you anything
about what it means unless you've
thought about it before so strong strong
really means that if you look at the
generating function c of omega is in
some a fee of x equals so i sum over all
vectors in 01 to the m the probability
that x equals Omega times a Z to the
Omegas all right product zi to the Omega
I so I'm sorry this is P of Z so Z is a
vector of complex numbers i from 1 to M
so this has no zeros in H to the M H is
the upper half plane
okay so suppose X is strong rally which
is now defined via this mysterious
condition which I'll come back to then
first of all then then X has the FCP so
so if it's homogeneous in this theorem
applies but if it's not humble but even
if it's non homogeneous you have we have
a concentration in equality so the
probability that f of X differs from its
expectations by more than a is bounded
by so e to the minus 3 e to the minus a
squared over 16 a plus 2 mu where mu is
just the expected number of bits that
are on
and okay so i'll focus i'll focus on
there and the homogeneous case and then
i'll end with explaining what is strong
property so I'm really property is so a
see I have nine or is there any
questions so far on these definitions
yes I'm sorry care wise negative
correlation and there's nothing nothing
that's nothing I have some examples here
which are so so besides uniform century
which is any determinant I'll process so
any process where the probability there
is so determinant that just means if you
ask what's the probability that the you
know the variables on some set sr1 this
is given by the determinant of some
matrix but restricted to the you know
the s by s the only the rows and columns
from s so there is some matrix
successfully so the terminal process it
looks like a very special definition but
besides uniform spanning trees there are
a wealth of other examples many of them
in the continuous room so I ghen values
of a random matrices in our paper has a
continuous extension but I'm so it works
for determinants I'll point processes
where of which there's a huge variety
but today I'm focusing on the discrete
case so that's determinant I'll so they
have so determinant i'll have the SCP
which includes the uniform spanning tree
and i said all these strong really have
the SCP they include besides a besides
the determinant i'll also anything you
get by starting at the deterministic
state Orton in the iad state and running
simple exclusion simple symmetric
exclusion they also include here's a
simple girl will take
bernoulli variables and condition there
some to take a specific value okay
that's also strongly and another example
is balanced Metroid so returning to the
pairwise correlation if you have the
basis of if you have a collection which
is the basis of a mate roid like the
uniform in the case of Eden Spanky you
just have to verify pairwise
correlations and you get in and you get
the stochastic covering property so
these are some examples with these with
these property so I think it's fair to
say most but there are some other
examples but most negatively dependent
process we care about have vs CP what
for well depending on what so I said you
can you place the strong greyle in the
strong really case you don't need
homogeneity with the statistical you do
you Amy that one with once you have
stochastic up covering it you you can
you don't need it but you get a weaker
estimate without the homogeneity okay
and so was wondering what are the
extreme weather okay I'm ah alright so
I want to indicate be I give the proof
and say something about strong really so
to move on so and how does this so let's
recall the case of X I you know iid
Bernoulli how is the concentration
proved there we take we start by taking
so suppose that X I is you know one with
probability P I we first observe
expectation of e to the lambda you know
x i minus P I so this is the usual e to
the lambda squared over eight right this
is just a very so this expectation is
just a average of two numbers this is a
classical say a fitting equality for
these two to point a to point fig it
though everything is here and be written
much more generally and then you get
from that that expectation e to the
lambda if you like it if you look at the
Sun so sum of X i minus bi so let's call
this sum SN so this is bounded by a eat
to the month p 2z course m lambda
squared over eight and then you get from
this is the probability that SM is
bigger than a is bounded by e to the
minus six to a squared over m ok just by
plugging in chebyshev to that and
optimizing for lambda now this proof
extends readily for partial sums of
negatively dependent more precisely you
just need cylinder dependence cylinder
negative dependence so you just need a
property like the expectations of the
product of X I is less than the product
of the expectations
this is they called negative cylinder
dependence where is what forever yes yes
if you have this property then the proof
goes through and this property is a
weaker than negative association but
this is about the partial sums so if we
a look at the classical situation you
know the most classical is partial sums
of independent variables there are two
well-known extensions one is two partial
sums of negatively dependent variables
which just follow with the u2 same proof
and the other is too Lipschitz functions
of independent variables which of course
follow using the so that using the
martingale argument for instance so
let's recall this so if they if MJ is a
martingale the bounded gap so MJ + 1
minus MJ is bounded by one then a half
dinga Zuma will be hosting tells us that
the probability that n k- m 0 is bigger
than a is bounded by e to the minus a
squared over 2m 2k all right and then if
you have a lipstick function of
independent variables you can just
handle it using the martingale you
obtained by conditioning on the first J
variables this is the idea we want to
generalize and that's where the SCP will
come in useful so
make sure my question would make more
sense if I asked if you have a
submartingale like maybe I'll come back
to that later so okay so we want to
mimic this idea so let's focus on on
this theorem for the homogeneous case so
so a natural idea is to take again MJ to
be expectation of f of x given x 1 up to
x j okay so if we have a Lipschitz
function in the independent case these
this martingale will just automatically
satisfy this now here we're not in the
dependent case but we can still do
something similar so mean let's look at
em j minus m j minus 1 and they claim
this is bounded about it by 2 I will
here's the definition of em jason to
bound this difference if you think about
it it's just enough to bound the
expectation of f of x given x 1 up to x
j minus 1 and x j equals 1 minus the
expectation of f of x given again the
same values of x 1 x j minus 1 but x j
equals 0
now if will bound this by 2 and the
other inequality will just immediately
follow it to do that we just can a build
so we can build X star which will have
the following form you know x 1 up to x
j minus 1 then we'll have a 1 and will
somehow complete it to XJ plus 1 star up
to XM star and we'll build X tilled
which will have the same thing but now
we'll continue with a 0 and finish it
somehow this will have the law of new
given x 1 up to j minus 1 and a
ending with a one and this will have the
law of new given x 1 up to j minus one
and ending with a zero ok ending at the
JC location is zero so we complete it
and the stochastic covering property
means that we can complete it so that
this part and this part are closely
related and so here they are separated
by one ok so i can complete it so the
remaining bits here are smaller but by
one from this from these bits is this
I'm kind of compressing a lot into the
notation here but ok this here and now
and now we're done because if we look at
this this is can now be written once we
have this coupling of variables with
these distributions now it's just the
expectation of f of x star minus f of X
tilde and X star next tilde just differ
by two so this is less than to just from
Lipchitz this is to cast a covering
property really making the right
definition you know does most of the
work for us here yeah well its way
stronger it's also a weaker so so are we
done here well you know in the initial
emails we naively thought were done here
but notice this is way off so there is
the concentration here is completely on
the wrong scale we have so think of the
example of the spanning tree right so
here we have concentration at scale
scale m so the fluctuations we can get
our order square root of M which in the
case of the spanning tree so think of a
graph with the end vertices and N
squared edges and this will so M is it
could be as larger than you know n
squared over 2 or something and then in
this will not give you this statement
but in
the K here you'll have an M and that's
useless unless the graph is sparse that
useless because telling me that the
number of leads on the spanning tree is
concentrated you know is is about in
with the fluctuation of about n is not
very informative because most of the
jumps are zero yes you're building well
so so I needs to use it and the key is
to use the right sampling procedure and
this is a very elementary point but you
know should be better known so this
point is emphasized in this paper on
determinants I'll process where we were
interested in sampling determine mental
process and this and so if you want to
sample from a homogeneous measure you
can do it in case steps instead of in
instead of the end steps and not only
can you should so so what is the point
here let's go back to spanning trees to
make things concrete but they want to
sample a uniform spanning tree that case
has many many algorithms beautiful ones
but I want to stick to the simplest
algorithm so here is one algorithm
enumerate the edges we have images and
for each edge decided we're going to
keep it in or not so for every edge the
probability it's in say initially is
just the effective resistance across the
edge so we don't need to use that for
those who know it right so I can just
decide is this so I have a graph right
so i can I said if they said Jane the
probability is the effective resistance
between here and here a you know when I
send the unit of current between these
two nodes the effective is from this
edge anyway it's some probability I
decide whether to put this in edge in or
not with this probability if I if I put
it in i might as well then glue these
two vertices if i decide not to have
this edge i might as well remove this
edge and now repeat on the smaller graph
so this is an Emmy step algorithm of
sampling the uniform spanning tree
requires computing effective resistance
every step then we can
and we can we can and need to use the
better algorithm for these kinds of
applications so we know the spanning
tree in the end will have n minus 1
edges so let's first de pick one let's
pick the first one that would be in so I
don't want any edges to be told that
edges are or not and I just want the you
know the optimistic information which
edges are in so i'm going to pick the
first edge to be in how will I take it
just proportional to the effective
resistance is so for every edge or just
proportional to the marginals for every
edge I know the probability it's
supposed to be in this time to attend
these probabilities of course add up to
n minus 1 to the expected I mean the
number of edges is going to be n minus 1
so take these probabilities you take the
effective resistance is normalize them
by n minus 1 now I have a probability
vector and I pick the first edge
according to this these probabilities
once I pick it it's in now I delete and
repeat ok I'm not sorry I contract
contracts another i glue the verses I
contract the edge and repeat so I only
have to do this K which is in this case
n minus 1 stages and so all right
something has to go so
so in other words I can have a vet in
the general setting I can have a vector
Y 1 up to YK these are a leisure
distinct in distinct elements of 12 m
and in fact the set y 1 up to YK will be
exactly the set of indices J where the x
j equals 1 okay so so the knowing the y1
up to YK tells me exactly what vector X
I want because X is homogeneous and that
means that i can write f of x 1 up to X
K and some functional F hat of a y 1 up
to why I'm sorry F X 1 up to X em right
here I had em variables it's a function
just of these k variables and now the
right definition of the martingale is
going to be the expectation of F hat of
y1 up to why k give in I'm sorry this
will be MJ will be this conditioned on y
1 up to YJ and again one can check that
it's still true that this the same
argument tells me that this martingale
is going to be a differ by at most two
at every step but now i have only K
steps so that's why I get the K here v8
is because this martingale differs by to
it every step instead of instead of i 1
but the stochastic covering here just
follows from the stochastic covering of
the exes so when I condition on having
so so this takes you know few minutes of
thought but just if I condition on one
more why I just know the intro and this
is because of this Pacific sampling
process property procedure of the wise
if I condition on one more why then it's
a condition that I picked one extra
location and that turns out to be
exactly
same as conditioning on that location
being on so so this see ya there's
something to check here but it works and
it means this martingale that most
differ by two so the the argument works
so in the remaining in three minutes I
want to so I told you what determinant L
is you know many know what exclusion is
what is strong really so so well I wrote
down the definition but so this a
polynomial was a property that has no
zeros in the purely in their upper half
plane with all the coins are a plane
this is called the stable polynomial
this is it yeah classical topic in the
geometry of polynomials and you know
with the various recent interesting
applications what does it have to do
with negative dependence so look at this
a generating function G of Z the
pairwise negative correlation has a
simple interpretation in terms of C of Z
so if you look at the partial derivative
so i'll just write CI for the partial
derivative with respect to the very the
ice variable so if what is CI if you
look at this function if you look at TI
of one so you differentiate with respect
to the ice variable and the effect is
just insisting that omega i equals 1
because the contributions with omega
equals 0 vanish so so CIF one is exactly
the probability that the ice variable X
i equals 1 and so so the negative
pairwise negative correlations just
means that CI of 1a CJ of 14 I different
J should be less than
a CO wealthy of one is one but I'm
writing it here to keep everything
homogeneous times C IJ of one so c IJ of
one is exactly the joint probability
that both i and j & here one is a vector
of one so i need all of them to be once
so this is just pairwise negative
correlation now in uniform spanning tree
one very natural thing is to put weights
on the edges and weights on the edges
correspond to having aim for will
positive vectors x CI of XC j of x less
than C of one I'm sorry p of x TI j of x
this is for for positive x and they say
for positive vectors X and this is known
as the Rayleigh property it comes from
the fact the Rayleigh a property which
is that when you contract and edge you
decrease all effective resistances so
this has led to this definition and
strong Railly so here is the a theorem
of a Brandon of seven is that strong
Rayleigh is equivalent to this thing
holding for all real vectors X okay so
you have a so you have to take C and
apply to not just to positive vectors
which hacker has a probabilistic meaning
you have to insist on it happening for
all wheel values and that turns out to
be the somehow the best notion we know
of negative defendants it's the most
stable under various a restriction so in
the last minus minute I want to
explain something about this
disconnection and then I'll be I'll be
done so we just explode say where where
this implication is coming from so so
let's just see where where this is
coming from so define for complex
numbers UV define G of UV as c of x + ue
i + v ej and because c is multi affinity
I find in every variable you can write
govt as the a plus bu plus C V Plus duv
where these have just the meanings of
partial derivatives so explicitly a is G
of X the eye of xu + c j of x v + CI J
of X UV so when it's because C is not
just a polynomial it's a fine in each
variable you have this this
representation and the fact that C is
stable has no zeros in there are perhaps
space implies that G is stable so G
cannot have zeros in the it we're both U
and V are in the upper half space so
because if it did in if it did then
please would have zeros where you know
they're in the upper half space with a
few two of them are in the upper half
space and the rest are are real and that
would imply by perturbation some
contradiction so G is also stable and so
it has no zeros in the upper half space
but G is just a function of two
variables so these are the kind of
functions one can compute explicitly so
what is it where are the zeros of this
so you can solve when this equals zero
right this equals zero when minus V
equals a plus B you over C plus D you
now what we want is so we know that G is
stable meaning there are no zeros UV
that are both in the upper half space
now what is this transformation this is
a Mobius transformation that preserves
the real line a plot you goes to a plus
B you over seen as you preserve the real
line so it only has two options either
it keeps the upper half space where it
is or it flips it right now because of
the minus V here we know that in fact
this must this must flip the perhaps the
upper half space I'm sorry this I'm
sorry the other way this this must keep
the upper half space in place because
this transformation because V has to
because minus V has to be on the other
side so now if you look what is a plus
bi / c plus D I right so you write it as
a plus bi times C minus di over C
squared plus B squared and now you see
that for this two key to keep the upper
half space you need a here that the BC
should be bigger than ad right that's
the coefficient of I here which is
exactly a
okay bc so is to keep so yeah so there
is one in here that so important thing
in the direction of the inequality so
right so again see what is p IJ p IJ is
the probability that both i and j are
inside so negative correlation means
that this is less than that so and the
end of the lecture so a right so this is
what negative correlation means this
inequality and this is what we obtained
here so that's the way that the zeros
are reflected in this but it turns out
that this is the right and negative
dependence property to get the
non-homogeneous case one just a uses the
fact that the sum of the variables for
strong rayleigh process is also
concentrated and then reduces the
homogeneous case the details are in the
paper so let me stop now thanks k ok
number of pieces needed to witness
Wow exactly you're talking about the
diameter of a boom three can you replace
k which is an honest one by dammit
retail I don't think so and so I'll have
to think about it more careful there yet
yes are there any results where you get
strictly better concentration than where
you get an independent case like is
there any condition when we were
together not that I know let me
emphasize that in this setting the
conservation necessarily can be worse so
if you have an independent variables and
then you copy them with negative sign so
you have x1 to xn I ID and then you just
write them with negative just write the
reflection so this is it a you know
negatively associated and strong
Rayleigh collection of variables but now
if you have the function the ellipsis
function which sums the first end
variables and then subtracts the next
end variables this is in effect doubling
each of the two variables so that's why
the constant in the concentration
inequalities and this generality has to
be worse so I wrote in eight here I
don't know this is if this is a sharp
but but you cannot get the same
concentration as for as in the IAD case
need absolute value the differences and
other sides yeah everything goes through
to us
group would work even if you put some
are Catholic so that they are close by
point right
you